hello everybody and welcome back you
knew was coming amnesia the Dark Descent
custom stories coming at you I just
wanted to get something with a little
scare to it after penumbra Requiem
seemed like such a disappointment on the
scare front I mean the puzzles are
interesting but ah you really need to
see me scream like a little girl I mean
tough through it all manly like all
right so I'm gonna be playing lacasa
which was um one of the top rated custom
stories in amis a little contest there
so we are gonna see what's going on
a scientist receives a letter from a
colleague but their plans are averted
adverted when the plane's engines failed
stranding our protagonist in the wilds
of the jungle will you survive all year
I will I'll bring it on oh that's nice
riding on off writing of a site in South
Africa made my skin crawl with
goosebumps in my heart race remembered
as the ones who saved humanities from
all illness all disorders all right
where am i oh as that jar I'll remember
that jar cure all at all possible Albert
Jones and Eugene Crowley very cool names
nominated for Nobel Peace Prize all
right
cool dad some books Oh funny gear your
bunny equal voice happening as I have
exciting news I must share with you oh
ho ho yes by a well-dressed me how dress
if hair was greased back his suit was
quite snazzy you say obviously there no
he told me that he knew me from the
research you and I had begun oh never
finished during her time at the
University Lizzie he didn't went into
great detail explaining how he stumbled
upon it while attending college and
found that we were onto something yes
sure I research for a cure-all
medication was closer to completion we
could ever have expected yeah I believe
it he then went on to explain that we
are only missing one chemical in our
experiment uh-huh sian tight small vial
of liquid was retrieved
huh oh that sounds familiar found the
source of cyanide and said it can be
extracted in great quantities but they
need more scientists to aid in their
studies uh-huh so that is where you come
in my friend yeah you're not my friend
buddy no no way I'm not going need a
scientist to get signed tight eh that
sounds legit to a star okay silver star
yay okay what else we got here um
painting anything up yep gotcha oh so
smart oh right what's in here no I'm not
gonna waste that on that anybody in here
who's there huh yes well I thought Apple
yeah
all right that looks about everything
okay all right Oh
exit oh cool
I expected the trees and bugs but I
didn't expect the planes engine to fail
I can only remember waking up hours
later whoa hello
right
of course I had to crash at night that
makes sense
all right let's do this
Oh on my feet ready to go this is still
a little weird oh good thing my chest
fell with me with all my lantern
everything useful there we are
laudanum all right bring it on
Oh who's out there nobody yep
whoa what the [ __ ] was that it sounded
like a cougar some sort of cat okay I
ran for what felt like miles in complete
darkness before coming to a small
clearing all right
that's interesting I don't know why I
needed a load screen between that this
but whatever I deferred judgment to the
developers okay interesting
okay where am I now Oh oil yay
oil box got a box I'll bring it on
anybody who wants to mess with me nobody
thought so plenty of oil
give me my box oh they knew better than
to give me a chair right what have we
got
okay definitely got some atmosphere dead
end
oh okay the tense feeling of being
watched was something I couldn't shake
but then my hope for rescue was renewed
each time I saw lights alright oh my box
ah now oh well I didn't need it anyway
when I got my fists somebody's face need
punching late no the box and a barrel
and a note I'm searching a tree 34 dr. G
Friedemann Friese been a week since we
arrived at the site our contractor mr.
blue LaRhonda mentioned that this
research outpost and the source of the
cyanide was being held in the confines
of this Parata Tim of course I forgot
the other doctors have made reports of
unusual noises coming from the depth
perfectly no I'm sure him there was
nothing but the wind yeah that sounds
about right to heard these sounds though
no you did this place gives me the
creeps
yeah I just want to finish gathering
this chemical leave as soon as possible
okay yeah you're dead yep what the
[ __ ] ha ha what ha ha what the [ __ ]
where did it it knows no dude who wasn't
even a noise was he even any is that a
door that wasn't even any old dirt he
was just there huh ok I no biggie where
did he go where did he go
he just went in the woods here ok oh ok
oh oh he was showing me the way
alright back entrance of the temple I
had no choice I followed that
monstrosity into those unknown depths
yeah it's a good good a good idea
oh boy all right oh well okay Min Ah Oh
get out of here I got a rock I'll mess
with me all right
oh this looks like the prison level oh
boy
oil all right keep moving here oh I
can't stand up to my rock
all right nope oh yeah nope not you
Journal I forgot an amnesia it's
different uh mementos that's it
something a prime up oh my massive
muscles maybe whatever all right what do
we got here um that's interesting
there we go crowbar entry 88 [ __ ]
freeze the team was right no they
weren't Don's were a warning we did not
heed it oh but did you just set up after
reaching a rich source of cyanide when
Birmingham our botanist went missing
yeah he's probably dead call for her on
the radio but got nothing both sorry
she's dead Lois our geologist went
missing during the search for Birmingham
leaving us with only myself dr. kleiner
and dr. Wang ducky back way member of
this place after much discussion we
decided to board the main hall wait
three days for the missing team members
to make their way back to camp and if
they do not show we will return to mr.
blue to form a proper search party okay
yeah they're all dead
dr. kleiner isn't that the name of the
doctor from half-life 2 and half-life 1
I don't know I got my crowbar moving on
I'll bring it on you monsters don't want
to tangle with me oh so badass
there we go yep yep boink oh oh I'm so
strong oh yeah crack oh yeah
up crowbar no crowbars broken oh wow
whatever I didn't need it
oh right where am I Oh something under
the stairs
I bet please as always ah there's never
anything under the stairs in these game
but this seam it's a secret passageway
no all right how do we got
Oh bring it on these halls were visited
before myself that was comforting the
conclusion of the past visitors was
unsettling though yeah they're all dead
all of them oh it's a bush all right
what we got here this looks nice for a
temple all right
oh okay not so nice Wow what the hell
yeah all right don't touch random things
learned lesson what's this all okay
thank you
bear rose apples boxes yeah the leg oh
hello come here come on
nothing barrel jump Oh so eat all right
anything in here yep gotcha oh I'm so
smart all right there's nothing what hey
hey
f you f off man it scared me oh but
who's there who's there no one that's
what I thought huh Oh see this go o go
that wasn't scary the last time all
right door ripped off its hinges not
scary what
invisible wall okay waterworks these
halls were off I read that before all
right bring it on
I see what we got here water um not
enough water for a water monster so
that's good not enough and oil all right
what no what do we got mechanisms and
the sewers missing a lever how did I
know that whatever oh that's right there
sorry I'm stupid good thing this guy's
smarter than I am
these guys named dr. white dr. black ha
ha ha
Oh ticky ticky timer tikitiki timer Oh
what's this oh all right oh man lock
doors lock door what's up okay
timer shut off maybe I got it oh I get
it I got to find the missing ah there it
is gotcha gotcha all right whoa hey what
what Mike what it just launched the
lever like into the thing that's weird
or whatever I got a hit all these and
then go insert this before the time runs
out okay I got it I got it I think I
think this is the way to go come on
let's go Liz ooh
all right here chunk oh thank you York
or precursor to your industries all
right one more one more no more is that
it did I get it I don't know did I miss
something uh all right what did I miss
what did I miss
I nope no
that's damn poop all right I have to cut
it here actually so thank you all for
watching and I will see you in part two
of let's play la caza
bye bye